please we have to get on that boat
abuela what the hell i'm gonna do with
baseball cards do you have any idea what
these are worth
let us do oh yeah marco
always making new friends donny you're
late where's alejo
he gave up his ticket for his family
[ __ ] alex was an orphan
alejo's not going anywhere anymore
come on let them on
good man get out of boxing now
gracias don't worry about it chamaco
here that's all i've got
this isn't right danny we should be
fighting up running to the young keys
alejo gave you a [ __ ] gift lyda we
survive
same as the orphanage same as the
academy
please no no this is a fishing boat
[Music]
before he was el presidente
me papa love to fish we would go out on
a boat
just like this and we would catch the
fish
and then release them he would say
it's not always about your stomach miho
it's about the challenge
except when he caught a big fat
juicy marlin he was too proud
to let that fish go sick there oh no
you have voice and yeah
i've caught a very big fish today
have an eye diego
diego
no way
i have caught you mijo now it's time to
bring you home
i don't want this anymore papa we have
no choice
let them go they can work make viviro
truth
or lies truth
they could be good workers
they could help rebuild paradise
but if you wanted them to live
you would have never set foot on this
[ __ ] boat
13 years old and diego has
such compassion for his people
these fish
we will catch a release
you've just seen another disturbing
lesson from anton castillo
passed down to his san diego as he
grooms him to become the future
ruler of yara the most important part of
crafting a far cry villain
isn't the fact that they're evil or
shocking
it's that there's someone that could sit
across from you at the dinner table
and charm you into thinking that
everything they believe
no matter how twisted or horrifying
could be absolutely true that's the
secret to anton's power
and we couldn't be prouder to have him
join the far cry family
now when creating anton we had quite a
lot to live up to
because when you think far cry you think
about its rich legacy of villains
which makes today a very special day for
far cry fans
not only did we get to sin into the mind
of anton castillo
we finally get to unveil some of our
post-launch plans
our dream was to honor the far cry
villains tradition
and introduce a brand new experience
it is time to see the other side go
further down the rabbit hole
and it's up to you to find a way out
tell your mother and sister to
you are alive
that is all that matters
peek-a-boo [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i
[Music]
i too am a king who isn't afraid to
slaughter to get what he wants
we're in my
is this a test a dream
an opportunity then i will not waste
you are beyond salvation
did i ever tell you the definition
you